and finally new rule democrats who one
year from now will be licking their
wounds and asking themselves how they
could have lost the midterm so badly
must instead ask themselves that
question
now
now you know now like
while there's still
time to do something about it a couple
of weeks ago amy klobuchar was here and
when i suggested the democrats need a
messaging czar she offered me the job
well you need a messaging czar in your
party
it should be you
amy i'm flattered
but after careful consideration i must
decline the hours it would take me away
from home would make it very difficult
on my family
[Applause]
but i will tonight once again break out
my coach hat
and try to point the democrats in the
right direction that's all i can do
point you in the right direction i'm
like deep throat
because the way this party is running
for office is making me gag
now
i know liberals think this country is
full of dumb white people but in our
democracy dumb white people make up a
substantial portion of the vote
the median voter is a white person in
their 50s who didn't go to college their
favorite tv show is ncis
and their pronouns are what i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about and
get away from me
in 2008 republicans only won four
virginia counties by more than 70
percent this month in the governor's
election there they did it in 45
counties
and this is what a lot of democrats were
told was the reason for that glenn
younkin's win proves white ignorance is
a powerful weapon racism still works in
virginia it's not the messaging folks
this country simply still loves white
supremacy
well i haven't worked up an official
democratic campaign slogan for 2024 yet
but i tell you what i have ruled out is
vote democrat because white people suck
that's
it's
it's it's like trying to get laid by
saying you're ugly you want to dance
you're alienating a whole lot of people
particularly whites without a college
degree which is most of them in a
country that's still 70 white i'd say do
the math but math is a form of white
supremacy
yes i know
i know every fiber of your being tells
you the people you really want to reach
are guatemalan teenagers and bloggers in
gaza but they can't vote
to a lot of folks in america you come
across as the cares about everybody but
me party
and it doesn't have to be that way you
can find ways to stand up for these
folks without being david duke
this month when the democrats finally
passed their big trillion-dollar bill to
rebuild our roads and bridges six
democrats voted no because it didn't go
far enough to address climate change
which i'm sure is true what does
but this was free money from the federal
government that would actually improve
their constituents lives i can see a
voter saying you know squad
i agree with you on climate change but
as long as it is happening we also need
money for getting the water pumped out
of the subway
can we do that before we build the
workers paradise
one of the first things biden did in
office was getting through a covert
relief package that sent fourteen
hundred dollars to well everybody
without a single republican vote and
today trump is leading him in the polls
you can give the people all the goodies
joe manchin will allow
and it doesn't seem to buy their love
why
why is the party that supports so many
issues that benefit the middle class
still considered out of touch by 62
percent of americans
in plain english nobody likes a snob
hillary clinton didn't have anyone on
rural research or outreach when she ran
in 2016 until the race tightened just
before the election then they hired one
and where was his office brooklyn
a true story
politics is local not locally sourced
it's not artisan
it's art and stand
your micro-aggression culture doesn't
play in the rust belt if a staffer hands
you a speech that says menstruating
people instead of women don't say that
say
women
don't put anyone fresh out of college in
charge of the campaign they've been
given participation trophies their whole
life they don't know how to win
[Applause]
james carville knew how to win
and he blamed the democratic losses this
november 2nd on stupid wokeness
to which aoc fired back that wokeness is
a term almost exclusively used by older
people these days so that should tell
you all you need to know
what
this is a term folks like you
brought out very recently and had been
proudly displaying it every march since
just last year the guardian declared
woke the word of our era i guess they
didn't get the memo from the mean girls
club
[Laughter]
we don't use that emoji anymore
woke please we say fetch now
what a great strategy never missing an
opportunity to remind voters how lame
and clueless and hopelessly uncool they
are especially since those are the ones
who actually vote
but okay fine what word would you like
us to use for the plainly insane
excesses of the left that are not
liberalism
but something completely different
because you can't have that word liberal
from us and think it should cover things
like canceling lincoln
and teaching third graders their
oppressors that's all your new thing
a more pertinent question to ask about
the word woke might be why in such a
short time has it gone from a rallying
cry to a pejorative
if the word only made you think of
rational deserved causes like
teaching a less whitewashed version of
american history
aoc would still want to own it
but it's a joke because it makes you
think of people who wake up offended and
take orders from twitter and their
oversensitivity has grown tiresome
that said
[Applause]
that said i would love to have aoc on
this show
there's so much to admire there i was
one of her first supporters for the
green new deal idea but that will
probably never happen because democrats
don't go anywhere these days where
they're not pre-adored
and that's my last bit of advice to them
go where the amen corner isn't
do fox news be brave come here go
everywhere winning is about expanding
the electorate
you